[Musik]
und da haben wir auch alle
persönlichkeit stetig über 15 anderen
schüler
fertig wo alles auskundschaftet und
andreja zurückhaltend erinnere dich
lieben menschen
also war nie der mann von beobachtet
haben es immer noch stimmt eigentlich
voll aktiv der andere noch an gene die
eigene familiengeschichte wenn meine
schwester schon sächsische und in oder
nach der wieder schlafen
[Musik]
für smarter man sich vom bauen mädchen
zog biologieprofessor ihn geschafft hat
und wieso sie auch nach 20 jahren
forschung noch mehr über das verhalten
der menschen herausfinden will
davon haben diese finden
die geschichte führt uns tief ins
hinterland von südafrika in die kalahari
wüste zweimal im jahr für die 24 uni
professorin marta manser für mehrere
wochen hierher
ich traf mark davon über 20 jahren als
wir beide laboranten waren und jedes
welt us tierforscherin 30 noch kaum
etwas
es ist ein kühler wintermorgen im
kalahari forschungsrat marta die mit
einem speziellen menschengruppe zeigen
draußen im feld mit dem paul gerät macht
sie sich auf die suche
[Applaus]
eigentlich hat sie die erdmännchen jeder
wartet aber kein signal an darlehen
schlafstelle also fahren wir weiter zur
nächsten schlafstellen
aufstehen
wechselt
[Musik]
direkt auf mich denken
ich traue mich nicht
[Applaus]
die hast signal
xie xuren und signal mit dem regime
empfängerin schau nicht da aber sie mit
relativ nachsehen martha lässt nicht so
schnell locker merke ich sie
verschwindet im busch eine viertelstunde
später taucht sie wieder auf die ganze
gruppe ist bereits aufgestanden und
wärmt sich in der sonne
es sind auch ganz junge menschen dabei
die martha unbedingt zeigen wollte
[Musik]
was wird da sie scheint die tiere nicht
zu stören
sie wurden für die forschung an menschen
gewöhnt habe tue ihr thema sagt
[Musik]
verblüfft bin ich trotzdem wie nah sie
sich kommen
weshalb die schale ist okay arbeitstag
von imprivata erscheint mir in diesem
moment wie ein teil von ihnen dann zieht
die gruppe los in den erdmännchen alltag
nahrungssuche am lautesten rufen die
jungen enthalten die älteren auf trab
die lassen sich von meiner kamera kaum
ablenken und graben nachlassen und
kleintieren blumenbeeten von allen
tieren in der gruppe getötet nicht nur
von den eltern
es ist auch diese ungewöhnliche
solidarität bei der aufzucht die
erdmännchen für die forschung
interessant machen
zurück auf der forschungsstation
sehr speziellen computer mir das kaum
vorbereiten ich vertrage und
verschiedene computer die daten erst die
analyse machen
mit computer mediziner und damit liegt
sicher wohl fühlen und den android
market auction waren 20 junge biologen
leben hier draußen
sie haben sich als sogenannte volunteers
freiwillige für ein ganzes jahr auf der
abgelegenen forschungsstation
verpflichtet marta ist dass professoren
der uni zürich führt die aufsicht mit
verantwortlich
kommt zweimal ist relativ unerfahren und
wir noch eine halbe jahr schon sehr
selbstsicher auftreten
wir sind gerührt sind die größte
verläuft und sie war für ihn erwartet
werden am schluss enz den weg
also sind wir wirklich den kann vom jahr
wachsen
matthias analytischen blick nicht nur
auf manchen gruppen
[Musik]
diesen worten begleite ich mag darauf
einen kontrollgang sie will schauen wie
es klappt mit der datenerfassung draußen
bei einer der erdmännchen gruppen
was jedes handy bietet aufstellen und
landschaft war 18 gruppen sind als man
wirklich mit laufen und denen geht es
nur 23
die volunteers ziehen los jeder und jede
fährt zu einer gruppe wir sind bei
samantha bis die erdmännchen aufstehen
hat martha etwas zeit mit der jungen
biologen aus australien ins gespräch zu
kommen
samantha ist seit drei monaten hier und
begeistert ich gehe gerne zu den
erdmännchen es ist einfach schön hier
draußen
ich habe für die doktorarbeit vor 20
jahren mit den erdmännchen begonnen und
bin dabei geblieben
sie sind einfach eine goldmedia da ist
viel mehr möglich als mit anderen tieren
wenn du eine familie hast musst du
kompromisse eingehen aber du weißt
wenigstens wieso man sollte aber keine
kompromisse machen wenn andere leute
glauben sie wissen was gut ist für dich
marta hat keine familie jeweils immer
wichtig viel zeit in afrika bei den
tieren zu verbringen
im prinzip nur forschungsobjekte auch
sie
gestand sie mir später zeit für die
datenaufnahme samantha lockt die
erdmännchen mit etwas wasser und
gekochtem ei auf die waage dreimal am
tag muss jedes erdmännchen gewogen
werden und dies mehrmals pro woche
wenig später zieht die gruppe los
auch bei der nahrungssuche werden sie
beobachtet nicht nur die erdmännchen
graben tief auch marta hat sich über die
jahre in die materie vertieft sie will
tonaufnahmen machen ist ein strahlendes
menschen und in diese gruppe nicht
willkommen
so mixa also das sind jetzt zwei fremde
menschen ist die gruppe zu machen mit
und er ist total aufgeregt markiert
vegetation vermisst vegetation als
wahrscheinlich
für das dominante und die auch weil die
hand hat ihr verfahren mit der üblichen
gruppe und den hat er einfach juni form
eine fremde männliche oder gar sie dass
sie benennen wäre aus der gruppe lose
vertrieben
[Musik]
es geht hier nun jeden diesmal wir kommt
mittendrin die beiden forscherinnen
scheinbar unbemerkt sammeln sie jede
daten und machen aufnahmen jetzt luft
irgendwo was also ist markers welt die
sich die erdmännchen inhalten füllt sich
verständigen
zurück in der forschungsstation im büro
der uni zürich sind bereits tausende von
aufnahmen abgespeichert berlin ist
martha assistentin ihr vor ort
ich möchte ein paar beispiele hören
das ist das heißt ich und wer für mich
und das weckte das team wieder neue
fragen muss mal da ist noch viel mehr
informationen generieren und den anderen
umstellen dass sich der umwelt zum
beispiel meine offen habe dort tor
struktur anders gesagt als sie meine
kapitals vegetationen ich merke man geht
in ihre welt ganz schön ins detail
auf diesem abgelegenen bauernhof im
kanton st gallen ist markt da
aufgewachsen als eines von sechs kindern
sie machte die volksschule und dann eine
lehre bei roche als laborantin holte sie
die matura nach martha wollte selber
bestimmen was zu erforschen sei und
studierte biologie cambridge in england
jakarta auf die erdmännchen der weg vom
bahnhof nach cambridge rückblickend für
sie kein zufall und vor dem herrichten
schweren weg sie richtig biologie
nach cambridge kam sie für ihre
doktorarbeit die traditionsreiche
universitätsstadt wo auch viele zöglinge
der englischen oberschicht studieren war
eine neue welt für marta martin hess
noch das gefühl dass sie überhaupt die
der welt von denen intelligenter oder so
genannte intelligente akademiker
werkschau die nicht stärken und so
wirklich bringen und mit zither sehr
sehr wohl fühlt in der universität
cambridge
martha bespricht sich mit tim klatten
brock er hat es forschungsrat in der
kalahari aufgebaut weil er aber bauten
saniert wird will die uni cambridge das
reservat verkaufen
in seine fußstapfen soll jetzt marca
treten und das reservat übernehmen
wichtig ist doch dass jemand weitermacht
wir haben dort in 22 jahren ein
wunderbares forschungs reservat
aufgebaut
wir haben einmalige langzeitdaten nicht
nur von erdmännchen sondern auch von
anderen tieren
es ist eine fantastische möglichkeit für
forschung und es wäre sehr schade wenn
es wieder zu einer ziegen farben markt
in ihrem element
dem fachpublikum in cambridge
präsentiert sie da es aus ihre forschung
alle hier im saal sind selber an einem
der vielen forschungsprojekten beteiligt
die im reservat mittlerweile laufen
[Applaus]
32 quadratkilometer groß ist die
spielwiese der biologen und dieses ganze
der wahl von cambridge an die uni zürich
übergehen
für den landkauf sucht mag da noch nach
einem sponsor auch um ihre
forschungsarbeit zu retten
schon jetzt kommt es mir vor als sei das
resultat so etwas wie marx hof noch
relativ viel kräuter man kann games war
wirklich sehr lange dauert das eine fast
100 meter verfangen hat und staubig und
elendig zugrunde gehen langsam stirbt
und das sind so sachen wie sie
eigentlich gern hätte wenn jeder wie die
abfall detroit oder glas das sind wenig
gedrückt da so machen
mit der gleichen hartnäckigkeit mit
welches sie sich hier um die details
kümmern
mit marta auch dafür sorgen dass die uni
zürich dieses reservat übernimmt da bin
ich mir sicher
am abend der tat der professorin ist
gefragt jede studentin aus zürich die
hier an einem welt kurs teilnehmen aber
ein problem mit eben ameisen experiment
ihr müsst nur etwas geduld haben
dann habt ihr das gemacht experiment
gescheitert doch martha weishaar
vielleicht ist das eine idee wir nehmen
halt nur ein paar ameisen machen ein
video und schauen uns das genau an
auch wenn wir jetzt nicht gerade ein
tolles experiment haben finden wir so
wenigstens heraus wie wir arbeiter und
soldaten auseinander halten was sie
keinen gesagt hat heute hat sie
geburtstag
später wir sind beim nachtessen mit
studenten des felt kurses dave der
manager die station hat man den
geburtstag gedacht
[Applaus]
der letzte
[Musik]
die
[Applaus]
[Musik]
martha führte mich noch einmal zu der
gruppe mit den jungen
[Musik]
diesmal waren sie sie auf anhieb
körper dort eine steuerlich so hart zu
boden seine eigene familie trug ihr aber
nicht unbedingt zweck terminlich
entscheide ich oder meine unabhängigkeit
des schon vorher an stand aber vor die
ganze karriere hier und jetzt habe ich
schon sehr lange der gemeindewald weil
da einfach goldminen ist für
wissenschaft und kombiniert
aber ich denke dass ich selber einer
großfamilie aufgewachsen und vielleicht
doch lieber leben oder kontakt zur
familie dass sie jetzt ja konnte hp 43
verfasst weil die vier in der welt
[Musik]